we're told that naomi lives at 2nd
avenue and 3rd street representing 2
comma 3 on the graph below
her school is at 4th avenue and 10th
street representing 4 comma 10 on the
graph she walks over to 4th avenue and
up to 10th street plot her home and
school on the map how many blocks does
naomi walk to school so let's plot her
home first 2nd avenue and 3rd street
which they're giving us the coordinates
two comma three so the x-axis right over
here this is this is representing the
avenues and then the y-axis here the
vertical axis this represents the street
so two comma three so
this right over here second avenue and
third street so you see here we went to
second avenue and then we went up to
third street this is where she lived at
home we could have also said third
street and second avenue
now her school is at 4th avenue and 10th
street so 4th avenue and now we're going
to go so we if we start at the origin we
go to 4th avenue and then go up 10 to
10th street so this is the coordinate 4
comma 10. so this is where her home is
this is where her school is they say she
walks over to 4th avenue and up to 10th
street so she walks from 2nd avenue to
4th avenue and then up to 10th street
how many blocks does naomi walk to
school
well as she walks from
second avenue to fourth avenue she's
going to walk two blocks one block and
two blocks you shouldn't get confused by
the they're actually marking off with
these lines every half a block so that's
one block to third avenue two blocks to
fourth avenue so that's two blocks so
far and then she goes from third street
to 10th street well if you go from third
street to 10th street that's going to be
seven more blocks one
two three 4
5 6 7.
so 2 in the horizontal direction and
then 7 in the vertical direction so
that's 9 total blocks